If you find yourself going into a freefall
inside a metal tube,
hurtling through the clouds
at hundreds of kilometers per hour,
and an oxygen mask drops down
right in front of you -
try not to panic.
Airplane crashes are highly survivable.
And here's what you can do
to increase your chances of survival...
Taking a flight on a
commercial airplane
is about as risky as riding an escalator.
The odds of being
killed in a plane crash
are 1 in 11 million.
You're more likely to
drown in a bubble bath,
choke on your breakfast, or...
die in a car accident
on your way to the airport.
Yet, we can all feel a little
nervous when stepping on a plane.
Here are 6 things you can do
to survive a plane crash.
Your flip-flops may be comfy,
but they're not going to perform well
in case of an emergency.
And neither will your high-heeled shoes.
The National Transportation
Safety Board reports that
68% of passengers in plane accidents
die from injuries in post-crash fires.
So go for long pants
and long-sleeved shirts -
they'll protect you from
flames and sharp objects.
And put on lace-up shoes,
in case you need to run.
Where is the safest
place to sit, anyway?
According to an analysis of airplane
crashes by Popular Mechanics,
your best bet is to sit as far
back in the airplane as possible.
Unless the plane goes down tail-first.
You see, there is no such thing
as the safest seat on a plane.
It all really depends on the situation.
Regardless of what
section you're sitting in,
know where the emergency exits are.
When you get on the plane,
count the rows to the closest
one so that you can find it
even if the cabin is filled with smoke.
The first three minutes after takeoff
and the eight minutes before landing
are the most accident-prone
times of the entire flight.
Make sure to keep your shoes on,
your seatbelt fastened
and your tray table up.
Put your carry-on items
under the seat in front of you.
You know why?
To keep your legs from going
under the seat and getting broken.
And pay attention to the
emergency instructions,
even if you've been on a
plane many times before -
not all planes are the same.
The first 90 seconds of a plane
crash are the most important.
Many people get so nervous
they forget how to
unbuckle their seatbelt.
Listen carefully to the instructions.
But don't just sit through the disaster
waiting for orders if they are not coming.
The first thing you should
do is to prepare for impact.
Bend over, grab your
legs behind your knees
and keep your head down.
In the worst-case scenario,
the cabin will experience
sudden pressure loss
and oxygen deficiency.
You'll only have about 10 seconds
before you go unconscious.
So if you see the oxygen
masks drop down,
put one on yourself first.
Only then should you try
to help someone else.
If you get to evacuate from the plane,
do it as quickly as possible.
Don't try to get your
carry-on to take with you -
in the time you waste,
you might end up
getting stuck with it on a burning plane.
If your plane hits the ground,
there's a high chance of it exploding.
Run - at least 150 meters
(500 feet) away from it
in the direction against the wind,
and wait for the rescuers to find you.
It's good to be prepared for anything.
But don't be afraid of flying.
In the history of aviation, it's
never been a safer time to fly.
Commercial aviation averages
less than 500 fatalities
per year worldwide.
Among planes that
do get into accidents,
over 95% of the passengers
get out of them alive.
Personally, I try to think of
turbulence like bumps on the road.
Helps with my flying anxiety.
That's a little tip from me to you.
Stay tuned for another how to...